hey guys I never showed you what I got
for Christmas I have to show you what
someone gave me okay this little bag of
goodies here okay we got the famous
luncheon loaf
I've never had that before I think maybe
in college it's a classic canned meat
product that sounds it sounds pretty
good then we have another one it's a
potted meat I'm not sure what that is
canned meat I don't know how they could
preserve it that long I mean it's
probably the shelf length of maybe 10
years here's the classic right here you
ever have the snowball oh it looks
pretty good coconut and marshmallow
cover chocolate cake with creamy filling
Ellie even have some vitamins in here
synthetic vitamins I remember as a kid
going to I guess it would be a wholesale
hostess place where you can get
wholesale you know donuts and cakes and
all sorts of cookies and we would load
up I would eat tons of that stuff here's
my favorite the ho ho have you ever had
one of these before
looks really good great can't wait to
eat that later okay then we have our
Twinkies right no shelf life we got
golden sponge cake with creamy filling
Wow
I used to eat lovelies by the way and
then we have something called the
scooby-doo I'm not sure what this is but
it doesn't have artificial flavoring or
artificial coloring so that's good okay
so they have ten in a box
eight nine grams of sugar times ten okay
oh these are fruit flavored snacks mmm
sounds good
okay so then we have our favorite
pop-tarts it's a limited edition and
Jolly Rancher flavored only 200 calories
pretty good tremendous amount of
ingredients I don't know why just maybe
just because there's so many different
layers this one has about 16 grams of
sugar
but we have to multiply that times 8 so
16 times 8 I don't know what that is but
that's a lot of sugar but of course I
used to down these so I'm going to thank
Chuck for giving me this thanks Chuck
this is a really nice present but what I
want to talk about is I want to talk
about some of the top reasons that
people give you to explain why they're
eating junk food or kind of
justifications okay and then what I want
you to do is I want you to type in your
favorite justification when you cheat
how do you make it okay what do you say
here's some common ones I deserve it
do you use that one or how about this
one I'm just gonna do a tiny little bit
or this is the last time I'm gonna do
this and then I'll start or I'll start
on Monday how about this one this is the
one that used in college
I'll eat healthy when I graduate yeah
how did that work for me no not not too
good
in fact I graduated in the next ten
years
I ate junk food or how about this one I
just won't think about it I'm just gonna
eat it and just not think about it so
what about you do is I want you to type
down your favorite justifier when you
eat something you know you shouldn't ok
type it down and want to check it out
hey tell me what you think about this
video go ahead and comment below and
give me your feedback